I often say about about tax avoidance is
its best envisaged as a massive pile of
premature baby monitors so you know when
it went over when it when it when a when
a baby is born prematurely and they put
him in this yeah look what the babies
lovely Fame and it keeps them alive so
so every time one of the big four
facilitates a tax avoidance scheme in
Luxembourg we've got less of them so try
to imagine a beach on the Caribbean hole
on the beach in the Caribbean that's
been filled with essential medical
equipment and that's that's what that's
what tax a tax avoidance knows I'm not
saying evasion that's what types of
audience facilitate hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Frances Foster i'm
konstantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you're bored of watching
people and the internet having arguments
over subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we asked the experts are
brilliant guests this week is a serial
entrepreneur Mike driver
welcome to trigonometry good morning
[Music]
given away the time of the day that we
record the show at so now people know
how to chase us down good problem all
over again before we obviously know and
love you but tell everybody who hasn't
seen you before
who are you what do you do what's your
background what's your story how are you
in the sea but you find yourself in now
so I start the beginning yeah yeah so
I'll go back I went to university came
out of university in 1991 I made the
mistake of studying economics and I may
be further a mistake of taking up a PhD
in game theory it's unfinished and if
any of you want to pop back up to
Manchester I never go in it so I came
out of
I was persuaded to drop that game theory
well I was actually approached by my
supervisor who told me there were only a
few people in the world who understood
game theory and I wasn't one of them
what is game theory just so well a lot
of people a lot of people relate game
theory to the film A Beautiful Mind osa
crow yeah John Nash but actually what
got my interested in game theory was was
john von neumann formulated game theory
to try and solve poker Wow he failed he
was a terrible poker by only lost a lot
of money at that's it which basically
summarizes my experience in the field
the very latest version of game theory
which you might be aware of was Yanis
varoufakis who we both know well Yanis
felt it was a good idea to try and use
game theory to negotiate with the
European Commission the European Union I
think that he was particularly
unsuccessful and I think he could
probably describe most of that fact the
game theory doesn't work in negotiation
which which some what's undermines it's
a uses I think as well so so so left
there I was persuaded out of that by a
friend of mine who come back from the
Caribbean where he'd been selling
timeshare and he said we should start a
business good what do and he said we'll
sell photocopiers now I didn't even know
what a photocopier looked like at this
time I'd never seen one I knew they
existed in concept but I didn't really
know what was but you know anything was
better than an academic career and so we
started selling photocopiers we would we
had a tiny little room about the size of
your studio I've given away the size of
the studio we had we had one desk one
phone and a rented Brown high and I pony
I don't if you've ever seen a brown
high-end eye pony I don't advise it they
were eight quid a day we had two grand
we are the serviced office and this is
how we started off and we literally used
to collect 50 compliment slips from
office buildings in the morning and we
would call those compliments slips in
the afternoon we didn't have a reach
their agreement to sell any photocopiers
if we were lucky enough to sell a
photocopier we had to go to somebody who
was far more experienced than us who had
a reseller expiry seller agreement and
who would extract the maximum profit
from us and that's how we started off
somehow by hook or by crook we grew that
business over the next 14 years and
we're adjusted servers to 300 people
covering all the UK largest independent
the UK we really ended up being a
technology company and to end document
management scan archive receive will
print all this stuff and we sold that we
sold part that's private equity in 2006
so I have what the America had then what
the Americans call a liquidity moment
which when you're from a background
which wasn't particularly wealthy is
quite nice I stayed in there in the
private equity world for a little while
the best description I can give you
lovely lovely gentleman I mean these are
lovely human beings basically he went to
very very expensive schools and weren't
quite intelligent enough to get a job at
Goldman Sachs the best description I can
tell I mean the best description I could
give you a private equities they
couldn't find a coconut on coconut
Island lovely human beings no idea about
business so so eventually left that
business and I decided that it would be
a good idea because it was something
again that I knew absolutely nothing
about to go in Siri Investment Banking
or corporate finance when I'd been
selling my business quite often your
your options but who can help you sell a
business the advice people give you this
little business is someone from PwC KPMG
Deloitte or ey maybe I should have said
all four of those what I would do is I
would sit opposite those those guys and
I would think two questions really what
have you ever done and can I trust you
and the answer those questions would
normally be not very much but probably
not yeah so I had the idea is could we
start a business that was providing an
conflicted advice to
entrepreneurs so that's essentially what
I do now started that business and over
the last eight years or so we have
helped probably seventy seven businesses
either sell or raise funds so we've sold
over two billion pounds worth of
entrepreneur the own businesses so a
little niche providing unconflicted an
honest advice to entrepreneurs so so I
probably met with more entrepreneurs I
imagine that most people who are saying
so I meet 7080 entrepreneurs every year
for the last eight years
there'll be 70 80 businesses two or
three directors self met literally
thousands of entrepreneurs so let's
start with that because one of the most
fascinating things I ever heard you talk
about was the entrepreneurial mindset a
lot of people kind of look look at
videos on the internet go oh how can I
become an entrepreneur and you have a
totally different take on what what
makes an entrepreneur well I do and yeah
I'm gonna sort of invalidate an entire
industry here I think but I don't think
you can actually decide to become an
entrepreneur I think the only way you
could decide to become an entrepreneur
if you could invest in a time machine
I'll explain why so so in all the
conversations I've had with
entrepreneurs I always ask the same
question I've been very suspicious of
where entrepreneurialism comes from I
think it might be epigenetic so I always
ask the same question is is what did you
do when you were a kid for work and did
you have any challenges or problems when
you were younger and invariably
entrepreneurs will have had difficulties
and challenges in their in their younger
years and the one thing you can
guarantee there that they have hustled
like crazy when they were kids they
would have you know for instance when I
there's the guy does the paper and I was
the guy who marked up the papers before
you got in to do the paper round because
of an extra fiver to be had for marking
the papers up did you I used to sell
porn mags at school yeah they used to
buy him cheap and then because we went
to a school and this was in the days of
the Internet we used to sell them off
from massive markups to you you
obviously have some lunch but it'd be
nice to combine both things that roam
around
spoiled something we carry on yeah well
you learn something new every day about
it wasn't his partner the closest thing
III would relate entrepreneurialism to
is is actually anorexia okay so the
latest thinking about anorexia is is it
SEPA genetic and epigenetic means that
circumstances or the environment cause
certain genes to be expressed that
wouldn't otherwise or over expressive
genes in anorexia obviously it's the
suppression of appetite which which in
which the environment in the
circumstances course and you know we're
seeing a rapid increase in in incidence
of anorexia at the same time we've seen
a rapid increase in the prevalence of
social media social media bullying and
so on and so forth being there the
adversity perhaps that causes the
expression of the gene and I think I
suspect something very similar happens
to the entrepreneur it would make sense
for entrepreneurism to be epigenetic you
only want some people to be
entrepreneurial you know if everybody
was entrepreneurial there'd be chaos
so so yeah I think in terms of the
industry itself or the industry of of
you know self-help books how I made it
you know baby I basically summarize the
how I made it books is is I went to this
news agent to buy my lottery ticket that
is about the simmer a similar amount of
information that you will get from from
a story about how somebody made it the
only real way to become an entrepreneur
will be to mentor a time machine travel
back in time and traumatize yourself at
the age of eleven I think you've got so
so so I don't think it's something you
can learn I think it's something that
that is inherent and and that sounds a
little bit unusual but it does explain
quite a lot of behaviors of the of
entrepreneurial people it feels more
like a compunction it feels like you
haven't got any choice it explains why
people carry on even though they've made
fantastical amounts of money which which
you often they've had their liquidity
moment they had the liquidity moment and
they're stupid enough to start another
business and do it all over again
but it also more subtly more importantly
explains a mode of behavior which is
essential in entrepreneurialism and does
not really manifest in other walks of
life and this is is essentially a way to
deal with an unknown future so a the
future isn't predictable because we lack
sufficient information the future is is
not predictable because it is
unimaginable so how do you learn to deal
with a future that you cannot predict
now what most people do is they try and
narrow it down to forecast some models
and all of those kinds of things which
which you know the futures waiting
around the corner with a baseball bat
for those guys that we carry in the
model you need to find a way to adapt to
the unknown what entrepreneurs do is
something I call serial redundancy so
sir we are done that season that is a
mode of behavior where I wave looking it
would be little bit poker so you don't
bet all of your money on one good idea
you trial and error trial and error
trial and error never bet your whole
stack never never risk all of your
capital so that when your opportunity
comes along the part of the works
whatever it is you get after it you know
you've tested the market the market says
yes and then you take the risk so it's
it's controlled risk it's not his recent
management more than more than his
risk-taking and that that mode of
behavior is common across pretty much
all of the entrepreneurs that I've met
and I think it's unusual that that's a
cross-section of people from every
background from every race from every
different part of the country in every
different part of the world would all
follow a very similar pattern would all
follow a very similar mode of behavior
and I think that traces back to them
being faced with challenges the
challenges in youth might have been
positive challenges by the way but
usually it will have been stress and
that's very Darwinian if you think about
it
need stress in a system for a system to
progress it's interesting you say that I
remember I'm a big fan of basketball and
I remember watching a few coaches in
America discussing how they scout
players and one of them said I never I
never pick a player from a house with
two cars in other words if the parents
were wealthy the child isn't gonna have
the drive that it takes to really be so
determined to fight through the injuries
to compete at that level to not get
comfortable once they get to a certain
stage and just to keep going and I think
a lot of we're talking about actually
applies to sport quite a lot as well a
lot of the people who make it to the
very top and sport seem to be coming
from that kind of place
well I think it's to say the other
comparison maker is sport is that is the
thing that you need to be very
comfortable with as an entrepreneur is
the word know as comedians we hear that
promoters an audience I I was I was
looking before okay today and I was
looking back at last 25 years and I
reckon I've probably done 6,000
face-to-face meetings in the last 20 25
years selling something at service or
products or or solution or business or
whatever it might be and my hit rate in
those 6,000 meetings is probably about
20% hmm that sounds okay for knows for
what yes but actually to set those 6,000
meters in the first place probably took
600,000 contacts well that makes your
success rate or my success rate not
yours I'm sure
more than 20% of people laugh at your
your jokes when you're in a success rate
of about 0.2 percent what's even more
interesting if you if you if you kind of
take it to the next level if you think
about negotiation which is an
interesting topic at the moment if you
actually look at those not 0.2% of times
that I have been successful within the
negotiations
I mostly lose you mostly lose until
someone says yes so you lose the little
battles along the way and eventually
someone says yes so you actually look at
their their actual times that the actual
conversations where you have come out on
top
they're a tiny fraction of the 600,000
times that you attempted to speak to
somebody so you're hearing now a almost
pathological level and I always say that
the winning is easy yeah I know how to
lose yeah and that that's one of the
ways I would define that their
entrepreneurial the entrepreneur isn't
somebody and we we see survivorship bias
we see the winners and we see them being
very good at winning actually most of us
we get here because we're very good at
losing it's fascinating that you say
that and you're talking about the
mindset because the average person
wouldn't be able to hear no that many
times without thinking do you know what
this isn't for me I just don't have it
in me whereas the entrepreneur or
somebody who is truly dedicated to what
they want to do we'll push through it's
like the story of Mark Ruffalo who went
years when he started out without
getting an audition you know living in
his car all the rest of it but it's that
design the determination to push through
that really sets the successful people
apart in many ways and also in a way
Mark Ruffalo probably had some
contemporaries yeah yeah people who
never made it and and the
entrepreneurial world has has thousands
and thousands of thousands of people who
never make it actually we all know them
a debt of gratitude they're the people
that we should be thanking really
because we are statistical anomalies
that so that's what we are really we're
not we're not something that that can be
constructed we're something that emerges
from continuing interactions in the
economy most people fail and we've got
those people to thank we can never be
sure and one of the most interesting
Soviets I think you really don't want to
think about it because you most
entrepreneurs think but let me give you
three categories of entrepreneur there's
those that make it by dint of being you
know fantastic business people huge
amount of empathy huge amount of
understanding of their market remarkable
in every way
tastic human beings okay so that's
that's the first category the second
category would be those that make it by
dint of having an awkward personality
and the third category would be the
lucky yeah yeah we all think were in the
first category now yeah the reality is
were in some combination of the above
and what's difficult for most
entrepreneurs to to reconcile is
separating the look and the skill which
is difficult I think in in in all walks
of life and you see very often where
where people have been very very
successful in one business and they're
not very successful in the next now they
just might be unlucky in the second
business but they might have been
looking in the first business so so but
we all think we're in category one
that's thing about a couple of years off
Mike yeah with the show well we're
almost not having to pay for ourselves
anymore I know advertisers will be
flocking after this yeah yeah I think
PwC and ey once again trigonometry
sponsorship listen let me ask this
because on the know thing it's
interesting because I remember doing
some research on this I was doing kind
of like a personal development course at
one point and they were talking about
this Eastern European guy I can't
remember which country's from who was
help he was a psychologist he was
brought in to deal with people at the
time when call centers had just emerged
like cold calling people on the phone
and what they were they were having
literally approach anxiety to the phone
because it was very uncommon in those
days for someone to just call you out of
the blue and start selling you something
so these people would pick up the phone
call someone up and the reaction would
be get [ __ ] yes pretty much right away
right so he was having to deal with him
what he did is he got them to go out and
make ridiculous requests of other people
to like go to McDonald's and order a
pizza or or go to a Chinese restaurant
and order a burger or something like
that and and he managed to train them
out of having that negative reaction by
just continually exposing them
to that and I think that resilience it
can be learned
in terms of being able to kind of take
and know so many times whether people
necessarily want to put them in
opposites do themselves in that position
there's obviously a different story
right can it be learned I think what is
he's taught them something slightly
different to what the call center is
asking them to achieve so so what
they've done is they've learned to get
over the initial embarrassment of
speaking to a complete stranger they're
probably the the probably helps to be
doing that in a group of other people
who were getting over the initial
embarrassment of speaking to a complete
stranger I don't think what he is able
to teach them and this probably goes
back to what was talking about before
he's not able to teach him to have the
necessary empathy to convert that person
that they've got over the embarrassment
of talking to to convert them into
whatever the call-to-action is for the
for the phone call I guarantee no matter
how many psychologists or how successful
he was about get him over the initial
hurdle of the embarrassment there will
have been 20 percent of people who or
smaller even but 20 percent of people is
the usual number who would have been
able to be who had the sufficient
empathy if you like to to convert that
phone call into into a sale or whatever
whatever the course of action is so so I
don't think he was necessarily teaching
them an entrepreneurial skill he was
teaching them a useful life skill you
know don't be embarrassed when you ask
somebody a really annoying and stupid
question you two seem to might you we
were talking about the mindset of an
entrepreneur and you you related it to
trauma how much of it do you think an
entrepreneur has a desire for control
and how much of it you do you think
stems from control because you will
compared it to anorexia I used to work
in a girls school my girlfriend's a
psychologist and she used to work in the
center for teenagers we have eating
disorders and she remember her explained
to me about anorexia that's about
control it's about controlling your
portion size it's bit feeling in a world
where you're surrounded by chaos but you
can control this one thing yet that
makes you feel more secure in yourself
do you think entrepreneurs who being an
entrepreneur comes from that in that I
have my business I can control this I
can control that I can control these
elements
I think it could be that okay that is
definitely one possibility I think that
will possibly be for a number of
entrepreneurs what I think it more
likely to be is that people are
uncontrollable so so I think I think I
go back to what I said before about it
not feeling like a choice that most
people who become entrepreneurs who go
on to do this sort of thing they've had
jobs along the way and the moment that
they are told to do something they feel
that's like deep-seated desire not to do
it yes so I probably go the other way
but III take your point on on the
control side that we tend we tend to be
control freaks
you know we do tend to we do tend to you
have to a really interesting example of
somebody who isn't an entrepreneur in my
opinion because literally because he is
displayed not having any control free
careers Luke Johnson I don't have you've
seen recently the patisserie Valerie
situation yeah where they've discovered
a a 94 million pound hole in the
accounts now a true control freak
entrepreneur will be able to tell you
the margin in every chocolate cake that
he sells let alone how much money he's
got in the bank accounts in the nearest
94 million so so he's interesting Luke
Johnson wrote the entrepreneur column in
the back that Sunday Times gonna be in
trouble now online which is which is
very interesting because and then and
this goes to to what I'm saying about
the future being unimaginable you know
when he was sacked comfortably writing
his missives about entrepreneurialism in
the Sunday Times he had no way of
forecasting next year the accountants
would find a 94 million pound hole in
the accounts of his business so so I I
think the control is the necessary
elements of entrepreneurial behavior but
I think the thing that shoves you into
it is the
actually the inability to submit to
control if that makes sense so it's in
the same and how much of that is
distrust in systems because I remember
that my dad was a solicitor and he he
went into local government because he
believed it was safe and it was stable
and that would provide him with regular
employment
I remember my father for no fault of his
own lost his job and I always remember
him coming to pick me up when I was
fifteen and him saying I've lost my job
and we were going back and we there was
no way of paying for things and my mum
ended up going back to Venezuela for a
bit and being in this bit of kit this
episode of care so me realizing age of
15 oh there is no there's no safety
there is no safety net it's all
illusionary in many ways do you think
that entrepreneurs have a distrust of
those particular systems as well where
they feel you know what no one's gonna
have my back
I've got to do it for myself yeah well I
think I think what most people suffer
from is a delusion of control it's it
doesn't it doesn't really exist I think
what most entrepreneurs and they might
not even be able to elucidate it but
what they instinctively feel and and
we've evolved over millennia instinct
and humility as a way of dealing with a
lack of control was a way of doing it
without being able to control the future
and I think what what pretty much all
entrepreneurs do is they instinctively
realize is that they cannot control the
future so to take your unfortunate
situation if you like you you had the
opposite of redundancy or your father
had all these eggs yeah in one basket in
a job that ultimately he had no control
on the desk of the destiny off if you
like he had everything on red yeah the
ball lands in black and here you are
yeah yeah in the situation you're at I
think what entrepreneurs distinctively
realize is is there's always a chance
that it can go to [ __ ] I remember we
first got we first didn't deal with
private equity and my first I was forced
then to to produce a budget and forecast
it's something I'd always avoided
previously and I was asked by the guy
from PwC you know what's the
cost line here 50,000 pound a month and
I said well it's for the [ __ ] watch it
well I said the [ __ ] that we don't know
what it is yet yeah take it out you know
take it out so so what what you were
what your situation was is you was
strangely you were optimized yeah yeah
optimization is really bad you know
Nature doesn't optimize evolution
doesn't optimize the only way we ever
Lucien progresses is by mutation
Automation is optimization as an
evolutionary cul-de-sac so you had
everything on red it came up in black on
what an entrepreneur instinctively
realizes he's never to put everything on
red
yeah yeah and that goes back to what
before was talking about Siri redundancy
and how you give yourself multiple
points of failure and I are the way I
describe is what an entrepreneur does
actually isn't even necessarily coming
up with a great idea what they do is
they fall over opportunity so I say stay
alive to fall over opportunities so
really good examples of this so take
Amazon for instance Amazon's
online retail business is it's debatable
whether that's even profitable I would
say that if you were to factor in the
way they pay the staff so so stop dates
from remuneration it possibly isn't even
profitable which will be a surprise to
most people Wow out what they do have is
a very very profitable web hosting web
hosting business called AWS now AWS they
fell over okay they built they built the
the the web hosting facility the the
Amazon Web Services for their own
business in order to sell you [ __ ] that
they can't make any money on the
internet and at one day they wake up and
go Christ we could sell this to other
people now that is a hugely profitable
business that Beezus never came up with
it he never thought to himself I'm going
to go he said I'm gonna go and be the
everything store
he never said I'm gonna go and you know
have this cloud business that's going to
be the most successful the cloud didn't
even exist when he started off so I
think that what entrepreneurs do is they
stay alive long enough to fall over
opportunity and again what we do
afterwards is we meet normal human
beings and normally human beings want
rational explanations for things so
rather than say well they just fell on
me you know he was the earth oh wow you
know let's do it well I started off with
his strategy it's all hindsight bias and
post hoc way because a mutual friend of
ours actually tells the story about
Jackie the famous comedian here in the
UK yeah who has this very sour dour
personality
and apparently this was he was
struggling as a comedian he really
wasn't having much head not getting very
far and with the kind of normal
character like a normal comedian and
then one day he got so fed up with the
whole comedy world and with comedy and
how he was doing that he turned up at
this gig and he was like you know what
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna one last time I'm
just gonna do this last gig and he was
really angry and kind of frustrated and
that frustration is what he brought to
the stage and suddenly he found himself
doing really well like he stumbled onto
this thing and it's fascinating because
I think what you're talking about really
is
in some ways the power of resilience as
well which is you keep going until
something falls in your lap it's
interesting there's a there's a book
called Auntie fragile by a Nassim Taleb
who we both met at kill comics he
actually goes one step beyond resilience
so he talks about things that exhibit
convexity and things they exhibit convex
there are things that benefit from
stress so it's not just been able to
withstand stress it's the it's the
stress actually the stress in the system
actually improves your your performance
yeah and I would say I would go as far
as to say that or all of the knows that
you get as an entrepreneur is convex to
knows for what what of a better way of
putting here is you actually get better
you you don't think to yourself oh my
god I'm a terrible human being everyone
hates me you think I just need to be a
little bit better yeah what did I get
wrong in that conversation what could I
said differently
what didn't I understand about that
person and so you are benefitting from
what what other people would see well
certainly the majority of humans would
see it stresses but you're getting
better as a result of interacting with
those stressful situations you're
improving every day so but you you can't
continue to improve interestingly
if you you don't survive so the most
important thing is to avoid ruin you
know if no one left at Jack Dee when he
became a sour face guy that's it he's
done you know he's not in the game
anymore and who knows you know if he if
he hadn't said this is the last time if
he said this is the second-to-last time
and sour face doesn't work maybe a
different personality would have made it
the next time and I think that's what
also what defines it defines an
entrepreneurial mindset yeah we're
almost congenitally incapable of saying
this is yeah I'm not doing it again
yeah yeah it's very much like committing
accept entrepreneurs don't pretend to be
left-wing Mike I'm a would point does
resilience and all these amazing
qualities in getting through it and
working hard and what point does that
tip into self delusion because we've all
met that person who talks a great game
and I'm using a metaphor of comedy then
gets up on that stage you're like oh my
god might you you need to cut it now
look I think I think I'll probably go
back the answer that question I go back
to the people who don't make it yeah you
know and it's probably the same in in
comedies at the same is the same as
entrepreneurialism you're actually
riding off the backs of the people who
never who never made it you know you
need although if everybody who stood up
on stage who decided they were funny was
funny it'd be a very crowded stage
wouldn't ya so we're all kind of right
so I I think I think you get you get two
things other people who try and make it
as an entrepreneur you get the people
who just try it doesn't work out and
they go back to doing a normal job and
all that kind of thing and that's great
but what you get at the other end which
is probably I think I think sort of
where you're a mare is something they
call acquired psychopathy and I was
asked a question recently at a show a
Kilcommons show where where somebody
said why two people in the UK or people
in Europe seller businesses people in
the United States just keep going my
answer was we're not psychopaths you
know so you get English guy German guy
ever I you know he can pay the kids
school fees he can he could buy a nice
house in Spain and drive a decent car
put enough money away you know I'll take
that you know he probably starts again
but he you know
he's relatively balanced in the way
thinks you know in America no they want
to take over the world you know and not
only that is they want to remake the
world into something that that they
recognize and I think we see that with
there's a controversial point for you
with somebody like Bill Gates and what
the Gates Foundation is doing in Africa
at the moment is that really helping
many many scholars there's a book called
the tyranny of experts if you want to
sort of who's kind of currentness with
the kind of controversy around comic
relief like if you want to research this
a little bit more there's a really
interesting book by William easterly
called the tyranny of experts really
what we should be giving to people in
developing countries is freedom and what
we shouldn't be doing is imposing
Western solutions from Western companies
pretty much all the solutions that
you'll find that mr. gates recommends
will be coming from people like Monsanto
you know you have to you have to have
certain pesticides certain crops and you
become beholden to the West you might
make some initial progress but you
become beholden to the master west and
what we really need to do what is far
more difficult to do because the conduit
of if you like of aid is much easier
when you've got a despot yeah yeah now
what we really should be doing and we
approved to be spectacularly bad at is
formulating freedoms where people can
start their own businesses and make
their own way in in a society and that's
obviously much harder so I think I think
you get this thing at the very top end
where people are you know become
literally trying to remake the world in
a way that they they perceive it to be
right
and that may or may not be helpful to
the rest of us all right well we can
wrap up the entrepreneurial section by
saying if you're not already an
entrepreneur don't even try
you are an entrepreneur you're probably
a [ __ ] psychopath so we can just live
with that we started just there talking
about some stuff that's a bit different
and I've always really enjoyed listening
to you talk about different ideas
because you have a very counterintuitive
set of ways of thinking about stuff so
you've mentioned in the past of the way
we think about everything is wrong or
maybe misguided or that we you know what
is it that we kind of don't get about
how the world is or ought to be well
let's take politics which things it an
interesting example at the moment so
people think or have thoughts for many
many years that the battleground is is
this left V right which would you see
you know greater or lesser degree across
the world see see I don't agree with
that at all I think the real
battleground that we face now is between
command and control technocrats on one
side and adapt and survive emergence on
the other so so I think we might be the
least per set perceptive most dangerous
people who ever lived I mentioned before
about the educational
institutionalization of hubris above
humility yeah we we believe if we think
rationally that we can understand and
therefore control and predict everything
this is a delusion we live life forwards
into mystery saying I said before about
the future being unpredictable it's
unpredictable not because we can't
understand enough about what's going to
happen it's unpredictable because what's
going to happen is literally
unimaginable a good example so an
example of that is quite sure how old
you guys are acting age 28 to 30 this
way your body attending
know what to talk about we'll talk about
internet internet dating as me there's
been a good example of something which
is is changed the world which is being
completely unimaginable so so when I
when I first started looking to date
people of the opposite sex you one would
go to a public house and drink and that
will be the circumstances whereby you
would overcome your fears without the
help of a stern European psychiatrist
walk up to people for the when you said
when you said the word Eastern European
I hear in every weatherspoon city senior
be going now you must approach woman so
you see you've got a set of
circumstances if you like where you meet
people and the advent of tinder at that
point it's not like you you weren't able
to predict it you didn't have it's
outside the realm of possibilities the
internet didn't exist berners-lee hadn't
done the first HTML page or whatever it
whatever he did and and I don't know if
he had dating in mind he probably had
porn in mind when he invented the
International to me as they as the
pre-internet person the concepts of of
tinder would be completely alien is to
be impossible to predict whereas the
thing is apparently now the Internet is
where the majority of people meet so
they are meeting for a I'm basing their
initial contact on a completely
different set of criteria to the Drunken
criteria that we based it on in the 80s
yeah which were definitely helpful to
certain people that's very diplomatic
but but if you look at if you look at
the way people meet now they meet
through a different set of criteria
well what's actually the outcome of that
the outcome of that is new relationships
the outcome of new relationships is a
whole different a new set of human being
who couldn't possibly have it existed
prior to the internet so and and that is
going to create an entire the different
society that couldn't have existed
because these people will be the people
who make the progress in medicine or you
know turning you know sunlight into
effect whatever they do into effective
power they will take us forward or
backwards the the dictate future
dictator of the world will be in this
this population of people who couldn't
have existed without tinder and that is
completely and utterly unpredictable
yeah
but sorry no no no because I was gonna
say it just sparked something in me
because I was reading about how the
nightclub industry said that their their
business model has been really badly
affected by tinder because the only
light in our generation the only reason
you really went to a nightclub which to
try and get laid but now it's you just
go online so why go to a nightclub bars
all right I read an article where where
the the stats and were argued that the
stats in the NBA on away wins yeah in
the in the basketball had steadily
increased so people who the stats for
scoring away from home it increased yeah
and they put down to the fact that the
players didn't go to nightclubs anymore
because they didn't need to really so
they won't go to a nightclub before the
game they wouldn't drink a load of you
know champagne or whatever they whatever
they get get down them in there in a
nightclub and they were better the next
day so there may be some there may be
some so why do we feel the need to
predict them if we if predictions don't
actually work as you say in they're
essentially a fallacy why do we feel the
need to predict why do people get paid
so much to predict fear okay so so so
the delusion that that somehow and and
this this comes down to what would what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
classify we're trying to categorize
we're trying to model the future so we
put things in categories we classifies
things and then we model in order to be
able to predict what happens in the
future and we do that because we're
afraid because people don't like to
thing that they don't know what's coming
around gonna I mean not that I in this
country that could be described as a
middle-class malaise so so you see it
really in the way middle-class parents
want to educate their kids with an inch
of their lives I had I had I saw the
business a few years ago one of the guys
who's in the investment company the boss
the business was explaining to me that
his nanny needed to speak Mandarin
because his wife would be speaking
French and he would possibly speak
English but he wasn't sure whether he
was going to speak English at home yet
because the children would obviously get
the English at school yet so he was
considering whether to learn another
language and speak in a non-native
language yeah Pollak your kid in a
non-native language my mom's affluence
but my mom's native tongue is Spanish
when if she was angry at me it was
always Spanish that she went and so
you're familiar with many many Spanish
words yes I am yeah the first loads
words I ever learned will get going you
at the Hacienda which means what the
vagina do you think you're doing this
podcast will probably not be broadcast
we've said so far entirely acceptable
the remit of what we do here but we do
need to be able to make decisions that
Mike write about the future like we need
to be able to make electoral decisions
we need to be able to make negotiating
decisions we need to be able to try and
have some idea of the future paths that
are available to us so that we can
choose between them right so how do we
do that in a world where we recognize if
what you're saying is true there's no
such thing as certainty and I think I
think that's where you start from you
start you start from a position where I
mean a really good example of this he's
the current debate that we're having at
the moment or or not having other
moments in this country which is which
is between between remain and leave one
of the things that I think is is I've
been fairly ambivalent on this I'm
probably probably the only person he who
initially sat on the fence
one of the things I've noticed with with
remain the remain arguments is that
nearly half the population seem to have
become experts in economics and and and
they are absolutely certain and that
there is there is certainly and there
can be no argument that we do not know
the path that will be followed if we
stay there is there is uncertainty in
staying whether there is more
uncertainty in staying or more
uncertainty in leaving is a matter for
debate but it is completely remiss to
imagine that there is some certainty in
a European Union and look you know we're
not allowed to have a debate where those
people who want to leave are able to
elucidate a leave argument on the basis
of economics or on the basis of some
flaws that they perceive in the European
Union they've all been tarred with a
certain brush you know which is which is
which really disappointing but I think
it's a really good example where where
you have nearly half the population and
I'm probably doing most of them a
disservice but certainly the vocal
elements of the remain campaign who are
absolutely certain of something and I
think if they're if if both sides were a
little bit more open to the the
uncertainty of either course of action
it might have been a little bit less
divisive it's interesting you say that
because Francis and I both wanted to
remain because we're good people there
we go that's that's it that's a
recurring joke on the show that pisses
off most of our viewers but now people
have started to demand it yeah yeah yeah
we get Twitter comments saying when are
you gonna start selling t-shirts we say
I voted remain because I'm a good person
so no well that the sell of remain is it
is is is it is you you you immediately
imbued with moral moral superiority to
leave people yeah so you know I
understand why that's a popular yeah so
so we both were to remain but we are
both increasingly uncomfortable and just
how polarizing this issue has been and
how certain people are that what there's
things like like I'm at the point where
I voted remain in the first
referendum but I feel like given that
we're sliding away from what the people
actually voted for if there was a second
referendum I may well vote to leave and
to support that decision and what you've
said is given me so much kind of
understanding of my own view because
I've always felt that it's an issue
that's not clear it's an issue on which
there are no guaranteed outcomes and the
idea that you know I voted remained but
the idea that I knew what was gonna
happen and I know what's gonna happen if
we don't leave and I know what's gonna
happen if we leave he's ridiculous I
have no idea what's gonna happen
I think there's incredible cognitive
dissonance on the remain side there is
without a doubt the euro is an
incredibly flawed mechanism you know you
can't have a single currency without
fiscal union you can't have fiscal Union
without political Union and his
political union even something that
could ever happen I very very much doubt
it so you've got a currency which is
benefited Germany at the core
impoverished but southern states and led
to incredible unemployment and the
complete annihilation of the of the
Greek economy although it is coming back
now which is testament to the resilience
of the Greeks who are absolutely
fantastic but but there you know there
is a flaw right at the heart of the
European project and yet nobody you know
very rarely will anyone accept yes well
okay we want to stay but we realize that
we're only safe because we've still got
the pound so so if maybe someone the
remainder side say we want to stay but
where we can guarantee will never give
up the pound and will always be slightly
addenda to the European project that
might have been a little bit of a better
a promoter etool than to say if you
don't wrote to remain then you're a
racist which I think hasn't hasn't
helped at all so I exactly agree with
you it is it is not clear either way and
anyone who is aware of history that goes
back
further than 1939 probably is an
optimistic about a union of countries
lasting forever because they never do
they always break up and how much of it
is do you think people just want to buy
into an easy narrative and then go I do
this I've remained therefore this means
this this and this whereas it takes time
and it takes the ability to sit and
reflect which is what you've done well I
think the more you reflect the more
complicated the issue becomes like the
more you try and learn about a subject
the harder it becomes almost to be
certain and that's I think the issue
isn't it yeah the European Union
contains some great opportunities you
know the ability to go and work in in
other countries you know for young
people in the UK is is a great thing but
it contains an awful lot of flaws I mean
I go back to cognitive dissonance yeah
you look at say mister Janka who is
president of the European Commission
so mr. younger previously prime minister
of Luxembourg previously finance
minister of Luxembourg so I saw a lovely
graph and you look at the amount of tax
avoiding businesses and the amount of
tax avoiding business who's registered
in Luxembourg and the amount of tax that
it's but you know revenue that's gone on
through Luxembourg at a low tax in a low
tax environment and it's nothing when
mr. younger started as finance minister
and by the time we get to today
Luxembourg is one of the biggest
facilitators of tax avoidance in the
world so so it's quite difficult
obviously the remain argument has sold
moral superiority to those people who
bought that that side of the argument
the reality is there's some pretty
unsavory details within the European
Union itself and certainly if you look
at the way Luxembourg the Netherlands
and Ireland have benefited from having
show
say useful tax Ranger it does make you
wonder I often say about about tax
avoidance is its best envisaged as a
massive pile of premature baby monitors
so you know when it went over when it
when it when a when a baby is born
prematurely and they put him in this
yeah look what the baby this will be
same and it keeps them alive so so every
time one of the big four facilitates a
tax avoidance scheme in Luxembourg we've
got less of them so I tried to imagine a
beach on the Caribbean hole on a beach
in the Caribbean that's been filled with
essential medical equipment and that's
that's what that's what tax tax
avoidance no I'm not saying evasion
that's what tax avoidance facilitates
now jean-claude younger at the top there
is incredible man of circumstantial
evidence although he denies it to say
that in some way he facilitated the
removal of essential medical equipment
from our hospitals and our society it
passed through Luxembourg was never
taxed and the corporates concerned now
have large cash piles in became an
island so or where they have them
instead of us spending that money on
essential services in the UK so so it's
not straightforward I think that's such
an important issue as well like I think
10 or 15 or 20 years from now we're
gonna look back on the tax structures
around the world that allow these things
to happen and we're gonna go how was
that even possible you know what I mean
like this idea that people can just put
billions of pounds away into these
places would not pay any tax at all on
it the Russian oligarchs can just stash
all their money in this place without
paying any tax on it we're gonna look
back on that and go how was that how was
I even possible well we might look back
even even more credulous Lee because
what they what we then hear is how do we
pay for it if somebody wants a
particular project or suddenly wants to
do something useful in society what we
hear all we hear from politicians is oh
well you know those priorities how do we
pay for it
I maintain there is enough money if we
just collected the taxes that are on the
statute if we collected the taxes on
products and services that are sold in
this country in the correct manner we
don't need any new laws there is enough
money for us to do all the things that
we'd love to do to help people less
fortunate but I think it's even more I
think it's even more important than that
so so human beings I think human beings
are a classical economists would have as
neoclassical maximizers okay that's
[ __ ] what we are with Darwinian
competitors yeah they say a lot a lot of
a lot of explanation the brexit vote
here so so what what what remain is tend
to think as if these people get richer
who are very rich get richer but these
people come up a little bit with them
then everybody should be happy what the
Darwinian competitor theory says
actually I want you down here yeah
I'm competing with you I'm not looking
at my my nominal there's a lot of
evidence for this actually that
inequality essentially makes people at
the top and at the bottom feel less good
about themselves be more more unsafe
have more mental health problems etc
because we're competing with each other
what that what that Darwinian
competitiveness that we have does is it
pushes money profits up the pyramid to
the people at the top that's just how it
is we compete with each other and those
people that top you know what they want
to do and what they are doing is being
pulled under up when they go there they
put a ladder up and they want to keep
other people the people that bottom from
getting up the top of weather where they
are and the history of man since since
we you know walks out the bush or
climbed down with the tree is is you
know more feudalism than it is democracy
yeah so so there is a serious side to it
the whole point of taxing the people the
top is to get it the money going the
other way and you want to get this
circular motion so so it's not that you
don't want inequality or in some way
that you're going to stamp inequality
out what you want is the people that
opted not to stay at the top and if they
do stay at the top they have to work
very hard to stay there and you
want this this opportunity in this this
circularity this circular flow and if
you don't tax the people at the top what
will they do they will do what people
have done is they will pull the ladder
up and establish their feudal empire so
so we eats actually it goes to much more
than just having money to buy [ __ ] it
goes to getting that hedonic treadmill
going where where we have a society
where we have that that movement
opportunity of movement for everybody if
we don't tax people the people that
stopped will stay if we tax people too
much they'll stop working so you have
this that what you have is going right
back to the beginning if you like aware
I said the battle between isn't really
between the right and the left the right
and the left both hold untenable views
about the economy so the right say that
by all of us acting in our selfish
interest the perfect solution will
somehow pop out of a benevolent society
yeah well that's clearly unlikely and we
end up with the feudal situation what
the left say is that somehow they will
change us into into our human nature
into becoming benevolent that's not
going to happen either no so so we have
to accept both we have to get both
things working so look competing with
each other
profits gonna go up to the top
government taxes correctly not too much
not too little and it injects that money
into the base of the pyramid to give
opportunities to people to get up to the
top of the pyramid and if you stop doing
that I I don't think we need new taxes I
think we have sufficient taxes we just
need to collect them so which ones are
we not collecting them well what we have
interestingly is we have a in in the
revenue we have tax we have tax
inspectors tax collectors and so on and
so forth all we need to do is we need to
fund the difficult cases yeah so the
difficult cases so we need to look at
everything that was done in Luxembourg
so there's a recent leak of all the tax
avoidance of is done we need to unpick
that is it legal I'm gonna say much of
it isn't legal you know because as a
barristers opinion because it was
approved by a big four accountant
doesn't mean it's legal so we just need
to fund
the revenue to chase the difficult
people what the revenue tends to do as
we all would is go after
easy wins so we need to go after the
tough stuff so we need to go after Apple
we need to go after Google we need to go
after the Starbucks we need to go after
the big conglomerates and say ok we you
know this is this is your tax
arrangements is it legal and we need to
tax people we need tax businesses for
the sales of the products and services
they make in this country and that
doesn't happen at the moment do you
think there's ever going to be an
inclination to do that though because I
mean there's there's there's a part of
me who's incredibly suspicious how much
of the government is tied into you know
these big corporations well I'll give
you an example it always seems to be
that a person who's in government
they're a minister they then retire and
then they take a cushy job as an advisor
at one of these big companies earning a
lot of money and you think well that's
not direct corruption but is it indirect
well that the revolving door is is very
pernicious and there's there's some
ideas that people had some ideas around
how you do this one of the ideas I heard
recently was anything that you weren't
above a certain amount five years after
you leave government is paid back to the
Treasury mm-hmm so so I absolutely agree
with you but III think it is it's not
it's not in the discourse you know it's
not it we're not particularly in the
public discourse is it we seem to have
had our our our discourse guided towards
looking at something else and you guys
have had some experience with this
lately we're looking at what they call
rights yeah so we're focused more on
rights and I just think that humans
humans want a lot more than just to be
consumers with rights you know really we
need much so they were creative we're
nurturing people we need some more
connections to each other
we need more ownership we need
businesses we need a patch of land we
need community we need faith we need
many many things which seem to have been
substituted by and I'm not this isn't
having the argument about whether these
rights should or shouldn't exist but it
just seems to me that they seem to have
taken a primacy in the discourse
whereas the things that have nourished
us as humans for millennia seem to have
almost disappeared from the discourse
but what these things require is
ownership and I think we're we seem to
be going is that we have a society which
be being pushed towards consumerism
mmm-hmm so so you become a consumer
rather than an owner and I think it's
very interesting when you talk about the
discourse we talk about what what you
know what what your distrust if you like
of politicians is is everybody thinks it
well nothing is being done about it we
don't read about it so much we don't see
it in too many places why is that why
are we why are we focused on a one
certain set of considerations not these
at least equally important
considerations that's why we started the
shows we're trying to have conversations
about things that a lot of people think
but aren't able to express and we're
kind of trying to bring down the
government from the inside it's been
absolute pleasure to speak with you
entirely expectedly I should say the
last question we always ask is what's
the one thing that no one's talking
about that we ought to be talking about
well I think I think I probably probably
hit the nail on the head no just just
basically that we're losing the things
that that give us a sense of belonging
that gives a sense of meaning and does
anyone talk about meaning anymore
everything's valued isn't it yeah Jordan
Peterson talks about meaning quite long
yeah not a man no he does talk about
meaning though so we like yeah I think
you know I think he not a Nazi in a way
that that I would I particularly relate
to he's obviously got an audience but I
think here no he's not for me well on
that trigger II know this is going to be
terrible the comments
follow Mike on Twitter he always tweets
and retweets interesting stuff as always
follow us at trigger pod on all the
social media give us an iTunes review
most important of all subscribe to the
YouTube channel and click that Bell
button next to subscribe button so that
you know when the video is released
thank you very much for watching and we
will see you in a week from now
absolutely and also as well YouTube have
a lovely little habit of unsubscribing
people if you could please check that
you're subscribed and if you have if you
have been unsubscribed give us a tweet
and we will we will complain to YouTube
and they will ignore us but anyway guys
thank you very much and we'll see you
next week bye bye
[Music]